hi everyone welcome to the first week in
our series of classes in this tutorial
we're going to take a look at how you
can use a flatbed scanner believe it or
not to create some very fine images of
three-dimensional objects like
microfluidic devices petri dishes and
other sorts of material you're creating
or working with in the lab now you might
be wondering why we're starting this
course with a tool that you probably
wouldn't think of for creating really
fine images of your work well we want
you to experience the fun part of
creating images at first and frankly we
wanted you to start off with some easy
stuff well relatively easy and not
having to worry too much about technical
issues which believe me will come later
that's a promise this course is meant to
encourage you to capture your material
in a number of ways and probably most
important to learn to see in the process
so you're seeing and will continue to
see all sorts of images that I made on
the flatbed scanner with different
approaches I'll go into detail for a few
of them in all of these tutorials and
we'll call them case studies you'll see
things that will surprise you and you'll
discover new perspectives that is new
points of view which might lead to new
thinking about your work try out your
ideas about imaging it won't take long
that's the nice part about the flatbed
scanner some of your ideas will work and
some won't believe me a lot of them
won't from my personal experience and
emphasizing what I said in the general
overview most of this is about
experimenting or in a way playing the
process I hope will become an act of
discovery as it did for me when I made
these images you should think of this
process in a similar way as you do with
your own investigations
so using this scanner can if you choose
come close to imaging with a microscope
if you make sure you capture your image
at
high enough resolution you can start
zooming into your image on your screen
and see things that you could not see
with your eyes and I'll I'll show you
that a little more later on one thing I
wanted to let you know that I digitally
clean some of these images so that your
eye wouldn't be distracted with dust
particles that's important for you to
know the decision of whether to use a
flatbed scanner is yours first think of
the size of your device or material I'd
say a safe bet is if you're planning to
see details from a few millimeters up to
a few centimeters but as you'll see in a
few moments you'll be able to capture
detail in the 30 to 50 micron range what
you'll see and show in your image will
depend on how you set the resolution in
the scanner setting for the time being
just think about it this way the higher
your dpi setting that is dots per inch
the more information you're sending to
the sensor the more information you're
sending the more detail you'll be seeing
and capturing you'll find all about this
in our how to do it tutorial take a look
at that after you've completed this
week's tutorial you'll see how changing
the dpi settings as we are seeing here
in these three images will have a direct
effect on capturing details why use it
instead of a camera well first of all
you can very quickly make some very fine
images without going to a more
complicated setup with your camera as
you'll see later in the next few weeks
you can show evidence that is that
you've made something or that you're
observing something you might want to
show a part of something larger a small
structure for example you'll be able to
share some observations quickly with
your colleagues you can consider it as a
draft image that you will eventually use
in a figure for a submission perhaps you
can even use the image as a patent
submission as something to think about
the wonderful surprise here is that you
can put a three-dimensional object on
the scanner and create images that
suggest their three-dimensional
yes you will lose step the field which
we'll discuss in the next tutorial about
cameras and lenses but still eventually
you'll create sometimes a
knock-your-socks-off image hopefully
you're interested in that sort of thing